it has been a day of firsts at the US
Supreme Court for the US Supreme Court
really the first time audio of the
curt's courts arguments was heard live
by the world and the first arguments by
telephone all it took was a global
pandemic correspondent David spawn shows
us tonight
oyez oyez oyez for the first time in
history the Supreme Court's public
chamber empty but the business of the
High Court continued
via telephone we'll hear argument this
morning in case 1946 the United States
Patent and Trademark Office versus
booking.com an intellectual property
case debated remotely without any of the
justices or attorneys able to see each
other at times there were a few
technical glitches I'm sorry
today's audio feed was streamed live to
the public also breaking a long-standing
tradition and a building that stands for
decorum unlike the usual free-for-all
questioning the justices today spoke one
at a time in order of seniority today a
rare moment by Justice Clarence Thomas
who once went a decade without asking a
single question during an oral argument
yes good-looking acquire an 800 number
for exhibits a vanity number 1-800
booking for example like many entities
that have learned to work remotely with
technology one attorney who has argued
in front of the court 21 times can only
imagine the challenge it's going to be a
chaotic situation I would think because
the justices are extremely active the
court occasionally allows same-day audio
from oral arguments in high-profile
cases like Bush v Gore 20 years ago but
that was tape-delayed
not truly streamed live I always thought
the court actually was doing yourself a
disservice by not just having live
videos I think the court would be very
impressive to people if they can
actually see how well prepared they are
don't expect cameras in the courtroom
anytime soon here at the Supreme Court
that justices Brett will be back at it
tomorrow on the telephone for the next
two
here in cases about the president's
financial records also the Electoral
College Brett the term for the Supreme
Court is expected to go through the end
of next month
David spawn live outside the US Supreme
Court David thank you